[Musique]
c'est quoi le problème est que 8 mai un
patient quel bord d'un méningocoque bien
vénère apparemment tous ceux qui ont été
en contact très chez eux et prennent un
traitement préventif tout est parti de
la partie ils voulaient tous et leurs
groupes dans un hôtel près du bourget ne
sait pas encore combien de temps il
fallait que ça tombe le jour de la
rentrée des internes et 2e crise et leur
premier stage ça va c'est pour 24 heures
s'inquiète pas je gère tout ça reste
de ton mec tu assumes
[Musique]
sa chance à paris
attention
on a besoin des deux soirs au barça
quand tu veux les supérieurs légiste non
mais à toi il ne voulait pas que les
giscard bénin agents pathogènes
identifier la mise à l'écart des
médecins prend jusqu'à 38 l'info
en plus en chine
temps chaud elle est relou lala sur 4
ans et
c'est quoi c'était à ce que d'accepter
dans le service
plus vous irez voir ça
tous les droits
de mazières tué technique et au coaching
on a une petite idée quand même de
combien de temps ça va du reste cet
isolement de temps qu'on sache de quoi
le passionnant
par le réalisateur de médecins de
campagne et première année
quant au secteur c'est simpliste
bike
sans prendre de l'eau
[Musique]
thomas lilti film des internes en
première ligne
une nouvelle création originale
hippocrate lundi 20h55 sur canal +
[Musique]